ya el con nancy pelosi precisamente
que partiendo de la cámara húmeda del
representantes de las principales democracias
ria y este proceso de compra política
de impeachment
tanto el presidente no se rinde
inmediatamente a las listas de cucchiara para
el anuncio que lo trajo de regreso a nuestros simos
via sisto llena caballos que la habitacion la
representante en ellos se extiende agua de
aquí en política, incluida la votación de un
salir y el próximo miércoles
semana y soy de Essen Barrios
Analista y paso a paso levantó su impeachment que
el último normalmente dura casi un mes
Procesador de acusación de Europa
Interesa si pregunta quién es si.
Pregunté, reduciendo la velocidad precisamente por
Los que le dieron la vuelta a Palermo eres uno
sana enumera primero pare witar que está en el
2024 no tiene la autoridad legal de
presentarse a las elecciones presidenciales
de nuevo en el segundo segundo exactamente es
que estos para crear un presidente el
presidente es que puedes ser presidente
simplemente rompe el orden
incitación democrática ya sea rompuy o
líder democrático aquí y allá hay
presidentes porque hay democracia
Las veladas de noticias sobre el estado institucional están a la altura.
presentar a ambos demócratas como
Republicano si la cámara es
representante tanto en el senado como en el stand d
Estoy de acuerdo con esta iniciativa obviamente.
Espero que obviamente lo sean
responsable sandro como y ahí estamos
Pueblos como un autobús, otros si están parados.
Aparece acuerdo con la presión media.
que llevas y el articulo 90 para solteros
en miano 5 intervenciones para regalos o que
sentimiento y cuyo sí es político y eso es
en el Matese escuchar a los congresistas que
Están diciendo que los rebeldes beben en el
Senado rápidamente al Congreso.
deja de mostrarlos rápidamente
a la opinión pública que el congreso
piensa en lo mismo nas para pensar en ello
estado para que la meta permanezca ahí
cuestión de tiempo el cristal katyn
factible y patinar el impeachment a corto plazo.
plus o y el frente duro bien tds sator
cazador y por supuesto s
cuando se presenta al presidente
elegido joe biden quien opina
del juicio político a Liszt y ¿qué pasa con
El Congreso emite los palcos
También demócratas que se presentaron tocándolos.
llegamos al tema del INPS local
serie que precisamente porque estaba muerta
entero hasta ahora saber pasar lugares
el juicio político varía un
que ya entrando va por el mar que el
Vale la pena pensar en el juicio político
mantener un nuevo gobierno la opinión
publicar en el insulso gerente de djhone delbono
debe ser sinfo caries la tensión y la
congreso para aprobar proyectos
iniciativa aprobada para aprobarlo 2
pollas brutales importa que sean esenciales
dispara y este nuevo gobierno se esconde y paga
demócratas que se oponen al impeachment
argumentan que el assen para que el
nuevo gobierno y función de la iglesia
deformar corregir el para los americanos